it's very cool to meet you thanks for
being here oh thanks having me yeah i'm
saying your name correctly right aza you
are yes and i was i was about to thank
you for that the amount of people who've
called me asa someone actually
introduced me onto stage this is
assabatiful and i i do you know how hard
it was for me to get onto that stage and
look at the guy and go thank you for
introducing me on stage
i'm gonna kick your ass yeah well
now uh you live in london uh you're
you're you're here in the united states
you're visiting you're you're pruning
the film how do you like the states what
what's making the biggest impact on you
as a guy who grew up in london um i mean
i love it here i mean the weather is
amazing and right
one thing which and everyone here likes
in and out burger right you know
all right cool well in the uk we we
don't have in-n-out burgers so we hear
about them and we think wow it's like
legendary it's like they write them in
scrolls and myths about this in and out
burger and yeah it's uh i mean they're
good but um i'll give you that but uh
they didn't live up to the to the myths
you think it was built up too much in in
england you think they built it up i
still no matter how much you build up an
in-n-out burger and i'm just saying this
because i i want free in-n-out
i'm being burgers
here but i hear choir music when i when
i bite into one have you sent uh have
you have you sent pictures back to your
friends back in london i have like have
you taken pictures of the i took one of
the the in-n-out burger um and they're
all like oh my god you're going to get
an hour burger they're like freaking out
your friends have high voices
yeah
uh now how are you handling the cultural
differences say here in the states like
what are you noticing is some of the
biggest difference in and out burgers
and hamburgers aside what are you
noticing um
i'm not sure i think we're pretty apart
from the accent obviously i think um
cursing or swearing as we call is
definitely something which i think is
quite a big difference in the amount the
swear words in the uk are very different
to the ones
over here i think i know what you guys
have what do you have you have bollocks
bollocks yeah bollocks are bullocks are
testicles yes
yeah i can say that i'm just i'm i'm i
don't think that's a shocking thing to
say i don't know uh so so uh bullocks
are testicles and how do you use it do
you say because sometimes you say it's
like um saying like if you stub your toe
you ah bollocks because you don't go ah
testicles i stole my toes it's not
necessary unless you've actually hit
your testicles yeah of course but no one
ever says ow my testicles no
they go out my bullets yes yeah well no
here they do they just make a lot of
noise uh
no one ever defines it so bollocks is
just like ah bollocks yeah okay
and then what's what's the other one you
have you have uh um wanker wanker yeah
i've never understood what wanker is
um
it's it's uh what's the equivalent here
i guess it means
i guess [ __ ]
is the equivalent i'm going to ask you
to leave
you're a very rude young man no
oh really so that's why so someone who's
a wanker is yeah
an a-hole yeah also i don't i find
saying
british swear words in an american
accent doesn't have the same
same ring
right yeah it doesn't it doesn't sound
the same you gotta you gotta you gotta
you gotta have the
yeah i don't think like wanker
to me that's it's not quite it sounds
like yeah the name of a duck yeah
come here wanker let's go
or it could just be someone's last name
hi bob wanker yeah nice to meet you how
are you
these are the little wankers
that's joe wanker billy bob lacker
you